friday, november 13, 2015 our country
france was attacked in paris around 10 p.m.
by multiple terrorist attacks in
the islamic state claimed by you
these attacks cannot go
unpunished that is why anonymous people from
all over the world will track you down yes you
the 20000  who kill the poor
innocents
yes we are going to hunt you down as we
have been able to do since the
charlie hebdo attacks
so expect a
massive reaction from anonymous
know that we will find you and that
we will not let go we will
launch the operation the  largest
ever against
you expect many cyber attacks
the war has started be prepared
the French people are stronger than
anything and will recover from this atrocity
even stronger
know the anonymous still offers its
condolences to the families of the victims
we are  anonymous we are legion
we do not forgive we do
not forget expect us